[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous nous allons
évoquer ici des sujets stratégiques et
sur ces dossiers sensibles je vais
partager avec vous mon interprétation
les ong sont devenus en 50 ans des
acteurs incontournables de la société
moderne et pour certaines de la
géopolitique mondiale par leur impact
auprès des gouvernements et du public
les politiques ne peuvent pas les
ignorer et doivent même les soutenir
s'ils ne veulent pas subir critiques et
dénonciations
s'appuyant sur des idées souvent
généreuse ou des valeurs morales elles
savent utiliser les médias et les
réseaux sociaux comme caisse de
résonance pour se positionner comme
référence dans leurs interprétations de
l'intérêt général
nombre d'entre elles apportent une
réelle contribution
pour améliorer la situation du domaine
dans lequel elles ont choisi d'exercer
d'autres ont pris une place essentielle
dans la vie des pays en distribuant des
bons et des mauvais points sur le niveau
d'adéquation des hommes des entreprises
et des états sur la base de leurs
propres critères elle couvre aujourd'hui
tous les juges en sélectionnant des
objectifs prioritaires qu'elles vont
surmédiatisé auprès du grand public
malheureusement le sectarisme de la
majorité d'entre elles les amènent à des
interprétations qui exclut toute pensée
ou comportements n'allant pas dans leur
sens et leur condition ne respectant pas
la présomption d'innocence elles sont
relayées par des médias en quête de
boucs émissaires et de thèmes
accrocheurs
indifférent aux conséquences sociales et
économiques de leurs actes ces nouveaux
ayatollahs s'impose par la pression la
peur où l'action face à des politiques
qui rarement ont le courage de les
affronter et de rappeler des vérités ou
des évidences pourtant factuel les
populations
ayant perdu confiance dans leurs élites
se laisse facilement convaincre par ses
ong qui leur apportent un constat et des
objectifs mais
ces affirmations
d'organisation voulant aussi bien sauver
la planète
les humains ou le doryphore doré contre
les prédateurs qui établir la démocratie
dont il rêve ne correspondent
malheureusement que de loin à la réalité
il faut que ceux qui se laissent séduire
par leur rhétorique en prennent
conscience
confondant régulièrement les grands
principes avec leurs objectifs
politiques
ne jugeant qu'à travers le prisme
exclusive de leurs critères n'hésitant
pas à tordre les faits et à utiliser
tous les moyens pour imposer leur vérité
les ong
développent des stratégies une influence
qui privilégie l'émotionnel sur le
rationnel il y a plus de dix ans la
fondation prometheus dans la seule étude
française fait sur le financement des
ong avaient brisé le secret qui les
entourent
la triste réalité c'est que 70 % sont
financés par des états ou des
entreprises pour promouvoir de manière
subliminale
leurs objectifs et ceci explique
pourquoi il est si souvent difficile de
connaître leurs vrais décideurs ou
l'origine et les bénéficiaires des dons
qu'elles reçoivent il faut dépasser
l'apparence de leurs programmes de santé
d'éducation de lutte contre la pauvreté
de défense des droits humains ou de
protection de l'environnement pour
identifier l'objectif réel recherché
certes on n'a guère de doute sur le but
réel des ong américaine
comme le national democratic institute
for green town un chemin inverse où
l'international républicaine et si tout
ou encore des quatre britannique créée
par l'oligarque russe mikhaïl
khodorkovski
c'est beaucoup plus difficile pour
d'autres et compris pour ceux qui
travaillent et ignore les mobiles réels
de ceux qui les emploient comme l'a
déclaré récemment le général buquet
commandant la direction du renseignement
et de la sécurité de la défense
devant nos députés si les militants
agissent en toute innocence
avec naïveté les financements
proviennent parfois de puissance qui
oeuvre contre les intérêts de la france
et c'est d'autant plus regrettable que
cela jette un doute sur de véritables
ong humanitaires qui font un travail
discret mais admirable comme acte aide
atd quart monde ou emmaüs
l'analyse des actions antinucléaires de
greenpeace montrent des parti pris
intéressant dans le choix des cibles si
la france est régulièrement attaqué et
nous savons tous d'autres comme israël
ou la chine le sont rarement quand
transparence y publie son classement
mondial de la corruption sur la base de
critères que beaucoup trouvent partiel
on peut s'étonner de la position
accordées à certains pays anglo saxons
par rapport aux pays latins c'est ainsi
que lors du scandale al yamamah en
angleterre qui reste la plus grosse
affaire de corruption en europe des
trente dernières années pour ceux qui
l'auraient oublié
je rappelle que c'était une affaire de
corruption entre l'arabie saoudite et
l'angleterre le royaume uni l'angleterre
avait versé des quantités folle d'argent
et avait fait des cadeaux somptuaires en
particulier des avions équipés il faut
voir comment pourra décrocher les
contrats donc en arabie saoudite
or ce qu'on avait constaté dans le
classement transparency c'est que la
position du royaume uni n'avait pas été
réellement dégradée aujourd'hui
les ong qui mènent des combats
judiciaires contre des pays africains
francophones ne se manifeste pas avec la
même agressivité avec ceux ayant
d'excellentes relations avec les anglo
saxons tout parenthèse on attend les ong
qui dénoncera les dirigeants afghans qui
viennent de quitter leur pays avec des
fortunes gagné par la corruption et par
la drogue il est temps de réagir et de
ne pas croire tout ce qu'on nous raconte
on doit s'interroger comme thibaut menu
dans le portail de l'intelligence
économique corps human right watch
s'oppose à la vente d'armes françaises à
l'étranger alors qu'elle n'a rien dit
pour des fournitures venus d'autres pays
est il envisageable que sherpa manifeste
la même vertueuse indignation
face aux achats de f-35 par certains
pays européens qu'elle a manifesté pour
le contrat des rafales 1 un bon nombre d
ong
ont réagi judiciairement à la vente de
systèmes d'interception par un métis en
egypte et d'autres entreprises au
moyen-orient mais les mêmes sont restés
étrangement silencieuse devant la vente
en europe du logiciel espion israélien
pegasus pourtant les interceptions
permettant à des pays étrangers leur
société de récupérer des informations
secrètes pénalisent les français et
l'emploi de demain dans les affaires de
défense et de sécurité
le réalisme oblige à constater que la
plupart des actions des ong semble liée
aux intérêts d'autres pays proches ou
concurrents il est vrai que nombre d ong
sont inconscientes des conséquences
économiques et sociales de leur action
on l'a vu avec la sphère du fauchage des
champs expérimentaux de gm de l'inra en
france il a détruit 20 ans de recherche
française et laissé la porte ouverte
grande ouverte à monsanto et à d'autres
grands opérateurs pour vendre seul leurs
produits dans les pays africains où wire
n'a pas oublié la campagne des ong
contre l'extraction du gaz de schiste
sur notre territoire compte tenu des
risques environnementaux
elle a d'ailleurs abouti à son
interdiction définitive on vient de voir
dans la sphère nord stream 2 que les
américains comptent nous vendre du gaz
de schiste et les mêmes mots et j'ai ne
disent rien il serait quand même temps
que chacun comprenne qu'il faut
réfléchir avant d'imposer un résultat
allant au détriment du domaine
économique visé août son environnement
social l'intérêt général
doit reprendre l'avantagé par rapport
aux intérêts particuliers ce qui
n'exclut pas bien entendu d'en tenir
compte
il est temps que les pays européens soit
plus curieux sur l'origine des fonds des
ong et que les médias s'y intéressent
que l 214 souhaite voir cesser la
consommation de viande animale et son
droit qu'elle utilise des films chocs
pour interpeller convaincant est
discutable
mais qu'elle soit financée en partie par
xavier niel qui veut s'impliquer dans la
production de viande synthétique est
inacceptable et cela ne compte pas pour
les ong qui font clairement de la
politique pour imposer un modèle de
société
correspondant à leurs attentes
c'est d'autant plus facile que certains
états les encourage
discrètement à déstabiliser d'autres
pays avec lesquels ils sont en conflits
sectoriels ou global quatre ong
ont porté plainte en 2019 contre la
france pour insuffisance de lutte contre
le changement climatique avec une
mauvaise foi totale elles n'ont
volontairement pas tenu compte que la
france est aujourd'hui le dixième pays
le mieux placés en europe pour le niveau
de pollution atmosphérique avec 5 5
morts pour cent mille habitants quand la
pologne et à 150 et l'allemagne à 154 si
l'on prend les émissions de co2
l'allemagne en 2018 représentait
22,5 pour cent du total de l'union
européenne suivie par la pologne à 10,3
pour cent et la france à 10% il est vrai
qu oxfam
la principale de ces ong a pour
directrice générale cécile duflot ancien
ministre et ex chef des écologistes et
avec un porte-parole manon aubry députée
européenne membre la france insoumise et
également ancienne étudiante à
l'université de columbia on comprend que
leur objectif final est clairement
politique et ceci n'a rien d'étonnant
quand on sait que cette ong fait partie
de l'open society fans des jeunes de
george soros ce spéculateur hongrois
émigré aux états unis qui a fait fortune
en jouant contre la livre anglaise avec
son agent il a déjà consacré
officiellement 18 milliards de dollars à
travers plus d'une centaine de ng de
think tanks et d'organisations diverses
aux usa et surtout en europe pour faire
aboutir son idéologie progressiste
mondialiste et libertaire détruire le
vieux monde et ses frontières développer
les flux migratoires
favoriser la diversité
construire une gouvernance mondiale on
l'a découvert au coeur de la révolution
des roses puis essayant de contribuer à
la déstabilisation de la russie avant de
s'attaquer à la hongrie et à la pologne
qui s'opposaient à ses idées on l'a vu
agir à travers des actions communes de
certaines de ces organisations en syrie
en irak ou dans les balkans on le
retrouve aujourd'hui derrière les black
live matters et la promotion du genre
peu de gens savent que si watch et sos
méditerranée vous savez les bateaux qui
récupère les migrants à quelques milles
des côtes libyennes et déversent leur
cargaison de pauvres gens en europe du
sud bien peu de gens savent que ces
entreprises sont financés par lui le
drame c'est que les médias sont victimes
de son réseau et des politiques de son
bord qui joue sur l'émotionnel pour
justifier et amplifier l'impact de ses
opérations afin de créer un sentiment de
culpabilité collective
comment l'europe peut-elle accepter cela
c'est qu'elle est en partie manipulés
par le réseau des ong qui s'infiltrent
comme l'a expliqué récemment un article
de valeurs actuelles
ainsi à la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme il est prouvé qu'une partie
importante des juges sont liés
directement ou indirectement
à l'open society de george soros un
rapport de septembre
ces récents du centre européen pour la
loi et la justice vient d'alerter sur
l'emprise des fondations ford et ce rose
sur le plus haut niveau de protection
des droits de l'homme à l'onu à travers
le financement non déclarés d'experts
auprès excusez moi du peu de l'unicef de
l' oms du haut commissariat aux réfugiés
et à l'unesco les sommes en jeu seraient
supérieures à 11 milliards de dollars
avant de conclure j'ai demandé à
françois martin président du club hec
géostratégie de bien vouloir réagir et
compléter mon interprétation
bonjour françois bonjour mon cher alain
je suis très heureux de te retrouver ce
soir merci à ton avis quel est le
processus qui nous a amenés là et par
rapport à ce qu'on vienne dire
alors je dirais que d'abord
pour compléter ton propos précisant ce
sont deux ong mais ce sont pas pour
autant des omp c'est à dire ce sont des
organisations non gouvernementales mais
pas des organisations non politique
alors je pense que le la différenciation
s'est fait dès le début au moment où ces
ong sont nés pour
corriger d'une certaine façon les
méfaits de la mondialisation galopante
d'une part sur le plan social et d'autre
part sur le plan environnemental soigner
les hommes soigner les plantes les
animaux donc à ce moment là un certain
nombre d'entre elles se sont aperçus que
la politisation de leur message pourrait
avoir un sens
d'autres sont restés extrêmement sociale
je pense par exemple aux multiples
activités de la gac ans que ceux qui
connaissent l'afrique
connaissent les lags à caen est
extrêmement populaire dans nombre de
pays africains wi fi nance énormément de
choses des écoles des programmes de
formation agricole etc les personnes en
entend parler et d'autres qui sont
devenus purement politique et qu'ils
sont restés à tel point que elles ne
sont plus du tout social comme tu l'as
comme tu disais à signaler pour le cas
de l'open society de george soros donc
il ya eu à un moment donné une espèce de
divergences mais l'idée départ qui est
le fait que ces ong
avait un caractère je dirais bénéfique
bienfaiteur pour l'humanité est resté et
elle continue à surfer là dessus alors
qu elles sont gouvernées par leur
intérêt ou par l'intérêt des états avec
lesquels elles ont certes elles sont
associés d'une façon très forte
aujourd'hui voilà ce que je vais leur
dire dans ce cadre-là du travail social
on est donc passé à la récupération
politique et avec l'aide de la
médiatisation c'est bien ça en
définitive oui oui tout à fait c'est
tout à fait ça je te donne un exemple
extrêmement simple d'ailleurs tu l'a
abordée dans ton propos tout à l'heure
c'est le cadet des migrants puisqu'on
voit donc on est surmédiatisée d'image
de migrants coquille qui arrivait qu'on
sauve alors que par ailleurs en amont de
tout ça il ya une mécanique africaine
qui est absolument atroce où un bon
nombre de ces migrants ne sont pas
chauds ne sont pas ne part pas de leur
plein gré maisons sont choisis par des
réseaux mafieux qui l'est qui les
emmènent et certaines sources disent que
parfois la moitié de ces migrants
meurent de soif dans le désert sont
abandonnés il ya une corruption
gigantesque qui touche je pense nombre
d'états mais pour autant on ne montre
que les images des gens qu'on sauve dans
l'eau donc en fait la surmédiatisation
amène à effacer
et à ne pas traiter les causes de ce de
ce mal donc là dans ce cas là le travail
de luigi et grave d'une certaine façon
voilà oui donc si je comprends bien ce
que tu dis le en définitive on nous
intéresse on nous montre ce qui se passe
en méditerranée on nous fait réagir sur
ce qui se passe en méditerranée mais
dans le même temps on s'occupe à ce qui
se passe en amont qui est beaucoup plus
grave à tous points de vue oui à tout à
fait si c'est exactement ça donc je
rejoins absolument ton propos sur le
fait que et si tu veux il faut démonter
maintenant cette espèce de rêve initial
qui consistait à dire puisque ce sont
des ong elles sont donc philanthrope etc
aujourd'hui on n'est plus du tout là
dedans est une des façons de le faire
pour revenir aux réalités c'est parler
effectivement de leur financement de
leurs liens de leurs dirigeants et ses
astra pour montrer qu'elles sont des
forces politiques pour celles d'entre
elles qui ont quitté le domaine social
initial elles sont devenues des forces
politiques extrêmement prégnante et ce
d'autant plus que nombre d'entre elles
appartiennent à des états comme tu l'as
dit ouh là on n'est plus du tout dans le
on n'est plus du tout dans le fil
anthropique merci merci françois pour
toutes ces informations complémentaires
très utile parce que je pense que ça
fait réfléchir tout le monde sur la
réalité de ce qui se passe et de ce
qu'il faudrait qu'on fasse
il est évident que nous avons laissé se
développer un tissu des ong
devenus des partenaires incontournables
des états et des références pour leurs
populations sans contrôler leurs
véritables motivations et finalités
comme le pire côtoie le meilleur nous
allons devoir séparer le bon grain de
l'ivraie dans l'intérêt général mais ce
sera difficile
compte tenu de leur impact sur les
médias et les réseaux sociaux certains
pays en europe et ailleurs ont commencé
à le faire avec succès en s'attaquant à
leur financement mais la france est très
en retard
souhaitons que rapidement le politique
prenne conscience de la situation réelle
et des mesures à prendre
à bientôt
[Musique]